what's up guys and welcome to total war
war hammer i'm joined today by my
strategic advisor which relates to hello
everyone I'm rich well a senior game
designers and you've brought this to me
today to show me one of the the armies
that we've not seen too much and also
some units that we've never seen before
so like these handsome chaps for
instance fellows yes yeah the Forsaken
the chaos warriors gone really really
bad yeah they don't look like they're
having the greatest of times but I mean
I'm not interested in their comfortable
I'm interested if they can fight and
break this Empire line also someone
who's a little bit too pretty to be
hanging out with the who the Kaos then
also doesn't is he wearing underwear
doesn't look like he's got a lot going
on there I don't know but he's gonna
check himself out with using shield
there in a sec yeah I'll just fix her
hair in the middle of battle we've got
our monstrous creatures up here to kind
of flank down the right our cavalry and
Hounds it's the left I'm just going to
spearhead with just those awful humans
subhumans villains warriors whatever you
want to call them see if you can break
this Empire line let's pause it first
just so we can get this charge going so
as my military advice you're happy with
this with this strategy I think we're
just going to get get the the masses of
the Warriors and the and the chosen and
the Forsaken just straight then into
combat with the Empire so they can you
know they're gonna take a few few hits
along the way but get them into combat
as quick as you can gotta how come up
here can he actually is just out of
range just got a new moving but he does
have an ability to get himself moving a
little quicker which you might want to
make use of just a few dawdles he can
bring victory TT these guys see on this
hill flank and these guys can if we can
hide them in the trees a little bit
we've got a new unit over there as well
the gore beast check chariot so that's a
looks a little bit like a gorilla he
pretty much yeah ooh some nasty old
spikes on his chest and see if we can
make the most out of that charge then
also with my sorcerer maybe we can kind
of bring him forward get a cheeky cheeky
flame vortex going yep make use of that
high ground there we're already getting
shelled I'm not biggest fan of that but
you will but then you know the rocket
battery is pretty inaccurate as well so
as many will probably just pass over
over your hips especially is the closer
we get I really want this hell kind of
start opening up I think he's nearly in
range the trolls seem to be keen on
earth ya wanna get existing just be
careful that they don't get isolated on
their own as much they can do damage you
know they're pretty weak on them Mariah
yeah Upsy Daisy let's move this guy up
swordsman great swords if we can get up
on this cliff and get good flavor text
I'd be a big fan of that yeah do some
damage against in Grace's cuz they can
look they gotta cut through your armor
like butter come on how cannon sometime
this week will ya look at the grouping
about those enemies there we go there we
go let's give it the boom as well oh
yeah I can't take a shot tech shop
everybody once in there we go yeah I
should love his energy screaming souls
all over the top cannon what a tease
okay maybe the flame vortex can do a
little bit more
mast in there those great sausage or the
human acts having a bad time as well
barbecue season a barbecued wizard
Caravan it I get those guys down there
sorceress still we can get fireball
lands this group as well these kiddies
up there they're not really taking note
of him you know you your your line is
certainly something hold it taking the
brunt of it okay well these guys can
start flanking it's just about time
let's get stuck in if we can seize that
great cannon as well and kind of take
that out of the picture I'd be a fan of
that all the Marauders and horrible
Doozers gonna sit here and soak up the
totally I mean you know they those hang
covers all those sorts of guys are going
to be no match for these chaos warriors
and if the bullet is going to hit anyone
I'd rather it hit the expendable units
then it's totally move up let's get this
car friends is going for my monstrous
creatures again I think oh no he's
turning around it's not bear of it oh
you can have easily come for sick valve
is ilysm I'm just stay away from the
route now he's going into the Marauders
so just before we get sick bout in you
know we want to make use of some of his
a special abilities day you get some
charge bonuses and some mellow bonuses
let's get them stuck in then right if he
goes up against the swordsman let's give
him a deadly hot buff just free hit
makes the charge excellent
cherry out of there so it can make the
most of his of his charges same of the
Lance's likewise everything the isolates
a the witch home to order order wizard
with seat belt seat belt being a duelist
should pretty much take them down by
himself where's that sly witch hunter
hiding actually I would love him to kill
that wizard saving buffing up always
friendly units so he proper monster
battle they're going on so the dragon
ogres glad it's always been tied up
though means they won't be at shoot me
in the back yeah they're quit they're
very they're very quick to get around
about it and just keep popping out shots
at you our friends really didn't enjoy
my wizard and his Flame vortex oh I
think he's come to take them out great
cannon are the regrouped where they
don't have a cannon let me make sure
they stay away as a point-blank shot
with that then spawn it's always has to
be mindful of that though just when you
think that you defeat as artillery
craters come and pick I'll get back
again this is going quite well so far
yeah it's little good stole that my
wizard has had enough he's like sorry
boys we're gonna go home watch chaos
Netflix this is too much for me the
wizard caravans also running which is
killed fine with that with the hounds
want a word neither hounds can take a
witch hunter so you can get sick loud in
on in any of the other heroes and Lords
where
is wizard areas again but want any of
them keeps peeing buffing up augment
spells are they it's like it's tied in
with the Demi grips than minute well you
know sick well if you want to kill Demi
Griff's Who am I to tell you know yeah
the witch hunt is all tied up with
hounds and Welsh a glass not doing like
though hey jagoff for your Wizards
sometimes the fighting is going on up
here Marauders are actually holding
their own although they are just
fighting a caravan with with jam on top
to be fair this year the luma lock isn't
the most competent in combat that's
celestial wizard I think he took a hit
from shower over there we go as we grow
up where we go I absolutely flatten
those ghosts big thing yeah the chaos
might be the Army for me nice and grow
ruthless lots of monsters spells seem to
be pretty effective and we got pretty
boy over here seem to have a good time
as well he did I don't think he's
actually the damage to her nice has in
place maybe he's got like a few scuff
knees and this lack of armor here might
have named a little bit but well thank
you very much for joining me guys at
home for four more on total war war
hammer make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot com
you